في وكالة المخابرات المركزية ، كان الموقف هو أننا
سنضع بعض الرجال على طائرة هليكوبتر
ونطير إلى أفغانستان غدًا
نعرف كيف نغزو البلدان
للأسف وكان على
باكستان أن تتعامل
مع الموقف الذي تعيش فيه معنا أو
سنقصفك في العصر الحجري
يا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
أمريكا
[موسيقى]
أجنبية هل
جاء لرؤيتي وأراد أن
يشرح لي أنه كان عليّ أن أفهم
تاريخ
طالبان وما إلى ذلك وقلت لا يوجد
تاريخ عام يبدأ اليوم
وهؤلاء موجودون هنا  هي ستة مطالب أو
سبعة مطالب كتبتها السكرتير باول
لأنفسنا على قطعة من الورق
وأعطيتها إياه وقلت من فضلك
تواصل مع الرئيس مايكل
وتحدث معه حول هذا ،
نحن بحاجة إلى نعم على جميع هذه الطلبات ، لا نعم مايبز
نعم
كان كذلك  كنت غاضبًا جدًا مني
واستطعت أن أرى أنه كان مترددًا ،
فأخذته إلى مكتبي الخلفي
حيث
عرضت نجمة باكستانية على جائزة
أعطيت لي خلال
الحرب السوفيتية لدعم المجاهدين
من باكستان
وقلت له يفعل  أنت تعرف ما هذا وقد
قال بالطبع إنه السيتاري
الباكستاني وقلت هذا صحيح وإذا
لم توافق على
مطالبنا فلن يتلقى أي أمريكي
واحدًا من هؤلاء مرة أخرى ، أعدك في
اليوم التالي الذي جاء فيه وقال
الرئيس مشرف.  قد اتفق مع
كل ما
قدمه اللواء مشرف أن
الرسالة التي نقلها اللواء
محمود هي
أنك معنا أو سنقصفك في
العصر الحجري في الأشهر اللاحقة
أه أستطيع أن أخبرك أن علاقتي
مع  قام جهاز المخابرات الباكستاني
بتحويل 180 درجة إلى
أي شيء نريده فيما يتعلق
بالقاعدة التي
سيعطوننا إياها وتعاوننا بشكل
وثيق للغاية
ولكن هذه القواعد نفسها لم تنطبق على
طالبان
وفعل شيئًا لم
أره من قبل.  شخص ما يفعله زعيم قبلي قبل أن
يخلع عمامته ويضعها على
المنضدة بجانبه
وبدا ميئوسًا منه لأنه كان يعلم
ما هي الكارثة التي ستقع عليهم
إذا ذهبوا إلى الحرب مع الولايات المتحدة
وقال لي أخبرني ماذا  يجب أن أفعل
ذلك فقلت انظروا ، نحن نعلم أن عمر لا يستطيع
لأسباب عديدة أنه لا يستطيع الانفصال عن
بن لادن ولكن
يمكنك أن تفعل ما لا يستطيع الملا عمر أن يفعله
لك لإنقاذ الحركة ولا أحد
يقول ذلك  يجب أن تؤذي الله عمر
ولكن عليك أن تضعه تحت
الإقامة الجبرية عليك أن تدلي على الفور
ببيان علني يقول فيه ما
تفعله ولماذا أه تحتاج إلى حشد
بقية أعضاء مجلس الشورى التي تحتاجها
وبالطبع لقد مررنا للتو
القائمة الكاملة بالأساس كيف تشن انقلابًا
واستمع إلي ،
قال حسنًا ، سأفعل ذلك وكان الأمر
وكأن وزنًا رُفع عن
كتفيه ثم قفز في
مركباته وانطلقوا عادوا إلى
قندهار
لذلك كنت  على أمل أن
تعرف أن عزمه سينجو من الرحلة
إلى قندهار ، لكنني كنت أخشى أن ذلك
لن يحدث ، وفي الواقع لم
تأخذ [الموسيقى]
واشنطن ،
كان روزفيل غاضبًا من الجيش
لعدم قدرته على إرسال قوات برية كبيرة
إلى أفغانستان  في الوقت المناسب ،
كابول جاهزة للسقوط وليس لدينا
أحد هناك في وكالة المخابرات المركزية ، كان
الموقف هو أننا
سنضع بعض الرجال على متن طائرة هليكوبتر
ونطير إلى أفغانستان غدًا
مثل دعنا نذهب لا نهتم لسنا
بحاجة إلى مئات الرجال ، دعنا  اذهب وفي
الواقع ، هذه هي الطريقة التي
بدأ بها الغزو حيث يعرف الجميع الآن
مروحية روسية قديمة وحوالي ثمانية
رجال من وكالة المخابرات المركزية
ويسافرون بأكياس من المال للتحدث إلى
مجموعة من زعماء القبائل الذين
لحسن الحظ أننا حافظنا على الاتصال
بهم على مدار سنوات
الحظ
[موسيقى  ] ربما تكون
العملية العسكرية التي
قامت بها القوات الجوية الأمريكية التي هزمت طالبان واستولت على
كابول
هي العملية العسكرية الأمريكية الأكثر ذكاءً
منذ
الحرب العالمية الثانية التي
تم تنفيذها بشكل صحيح تمامًا في رأيي ، إلا أن
قلة قليلة جدًا من القوات
الجوية الأمريكية من
حلفاء القبائل التي تم
تدميرها لطالبان
كانت البداية واضحة تمامًا
نحن
نعرف كيف نغزو البلدان
للأسف
[موسيقى]
مثل 2002 2003 حتى 2004
كان الوضع يتحسن ، يمكنك السفر من
هنا إلى أي جزء من البلاد لم
يكن هناك أي
منطقة وسيطرة طالبان الخاصة بهم
كلنا
أخذنا
أعيننا  من الكرة
وبعض
في الإدارة في منتصف عام
بدأنا بالتفكير في العراق
ووضعنا أفغانستان
بصراحة على الطيار الآلي
وتحويل انتباهنا إلى العراق
وترك أفغانستان فقط ينجرفون
إلى
فرق
30000 جندي في أفغانستان وقال
18 شهرًا من الآن  نحن نخرجهم ،
حسنًا ، من
الواضح أن هذا أمر سخيف ، أعني
عدم إرسالهم أو إرسالهم وإخبارهم
بالعودة إلى المنزل عندما ينهون المهمة
في
تلك باكستان اتخذت
قرارًا مدروسًا
ليكون جزءًا من  التحالف
مع الولايات المتحدة لمحاربة
الإرهاب
بجميع أشكاله
أينما كان ،
فربما نحن
بالطبع
يلعبون لعبة مزدوجة
كانوا يفعلونها بما يكفي لإبعاد
الأمريكيين عن ظهورهم والحصول على
المساعدة من أمريكا في نفس الوقت
المؤكد.
كانت عناصر من القوات المسلحة الباكستانية تدعم
طالبان ، لكن إذا نظرت إلى الأمر من
وجهة نظرهم ،
فإنهم كانوا يحمون
أنفسهم لأنهم لم يكونوا متأكدين مما سيحققه
المستقبل من 100
تعاون
بالتأكيد لم يأتِ أبدًا من باكستان
وكان خطأ إدارة الأدغال هو
يعتقدون أنها ستكون
عملية تدريجية ، كانوا سعداء بتعاون 30 و 40
بالمائة في البداية ،
ثم 50 بالمائة لم يفهموا أبدًا
أنه طالما أنها ليست 100 بالمائة ،
فسوف تتجدد نفسها.
يقول الناس
لماذا لا ننتصر في الحرب في أفغانستان
أقول إنك انتصرت في الحرب في أفغانستان بعد
حوالي خمسة أشهر ،
وقد تم تحقيق جميع أهدافك ،
ثم توصلت إلى
خطة جديدة تمامًا لتحويل أفغانستان
إلى سويسرا في وسط آسيا
مع
فوجي
الأجنبي [
تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أنت